hi there Steve Kaufman here I was asked
to do a video today in fact about the
differences between learning Japanese
and Chinese so I always appreciate
getting specific requests it's always
nice to respond to you know listeners
viewers who are interested in the
particular subject so I thought I would
try to look at these differences both in
terms of how I study the two languages
and I'm going to throw Korean in as well
three Asian languages and what I think
are general differences in terms of
difficulty and so forth remember that I
studied Chinese as a full-time language
student paid for by the Canadian
government because I was a diplomat and
they were training me to learn Chinese I
had three hours in the morning and then
I had lots of hours full time to devote
to reading and listening and and
building up my skill level in Chinese I
lived in Hong Kong which was not a place
for Mandarin Chinese was spoken so I did
not have the benefit of being immersed
in the language in Japan I studied it
entirely on my own but I had the
advantage of living in Japan Korean I am
studying here in Vancouver so again I'm
on my own but again don't have the
language surrounding me so if we look at
first of all as you probably know or may
know I believe that the best way to
learn a language is to devote a lot of
time to listening and reading and
vocabulary accumulation you can speak
whenever you want to start speaking but
until you have a lot of words it's very
difficult to have meaningful
conversations and I like doing things
that are meaningful in the language now
with Chinese an immediate problem is
that until you have learned enough
characters you cannot read anything very
interesting or meaningful in the
language so that makes Chinese quite
difficult I made a special effort to
learn the most frequent 1,000 character
I have flashcards for them I used to
write them out on these checkered you
know exercise books where I had sort of
a primitive spaced repetition system
that I've described before where I would
write the character out seven or eight
ten times and then put it over you know
put the meaning or the pronunciation
over three or four columns to the right
pick up another flashcard do the same
thing until I ran into that first
character and I would do that literally
every day so that once I had the
thousand most common characters that I
deliberately wrote out longhand to try
to learn thereafter as I encountered
characters in my reading it was enough
to write them out five six seven ten
times of course you keep on forgetting
but forgetting rewriting relearning
seeing them in context and eventually
they started to stick with characters
after a while you start to get used to
the different components the radicals as
they're called so that that helps you
remember these characters you get better
and better at learning them when you
first start out it seems like an
impossible task to remember you know the
stroke order and strokes for 10 12 13
different strokes for just one character
so the reading in the case of Chinese
initially a big obstacle but once you
have the characters it becomes very easy
to build vocabulary because combinations
different combinations of the characters
that you now know it correspond to
different words the way we count words
in English so that was with regard to
reading in Japanese the now bear in mind
when I studied Chinese I had to write an
exam so I knew that after as it turned
out after less than a year I would have
to be able to translate newspaper
editorials from Chinese into English
from English into Chinese right a
diplomatic note so I had to focus on my
writing with Japanese I was studying it
only in order to be able to use it and
therefore I essentially never wrote it
so as long as I could read it I was
happy the problem in Japanese is that a
lot of the sort of begin
our material the easier reading material
is very heavy to hiragana and I found it
very difficult to read hiragana the
other thing is because it's the hiragana
is a syllable type system so I wanted to
move two texts that had a lot of
characters as as soon as possible like
newspapers and stuff like that but of
course I couldn't understand the
newspapers it was too quick for me if I
listen to the radio news or something so
I was stocked with reading a lot of the
beginner material and one of the
mysteries for me and language
instruction is the people who write
textbooks I like to provide you know
children's stories stories about I can't
remember who taught all who wrote a
turtle underneath the ocean fairy
stories the stories about flying carp on
whatever festival day you know subjects
that I would never read about in English
I would have no interest in these
subjects whatsoever and yet and the same
is true in Korean lots of these quote
cultural type content items for
beginners or children's stories which
are really not a very much interest so I
remember there was a series called Naga
Numa where I just read on and on and on
and in hiragana and found it quite
boring and I was very happy when I was
able to get two texts that were more of
more interest so in a sense Japanese is
easier to read because it's a phonetic
system but there are two different
phonetic systems and I never enjoyed
reading in katakana and you don't get
enough of a dosage of it at least I
didn't that I'm still not very good at
my katakana and I prefer to read texts
with a lot of characters even if at
times I pronounce these characters in
the Chinese way I know what the meaning
is so reading wise Japanese is probably
easier because you only need about 2,000
characters whereas in Chinese you have
only characters to go on to go with
right the reading of Korean is the
easiest of all because it's all it's an
alphabet like we understand it now for
that but the difficulty with Korean is
just as in Japanese or perhaps slightly
more so there are a lot of Chinese word
it's words that are based on Chinese and
if you read them in the phonetic script
you often don't know what they are so
that presents certain difficulties so
yeah for Japanese definitely you should
learn the Chinese characters because it
makes it a lot easier to read reading is
a major tool for language learning for
vocabulary accumulation I don't know how
you would accumulate sort of an adult
vocabulary in China in Japanese if you
can't read characters and read
interesting and meaningful text in so
far as the sort of word order or
grammatical structure of the languages I
think every language is different and
you just have to get used to it when you
start out it feels strange but probably
Chinese is easier in fact not probably
certainly Chinese is easier than
Japanese or Korean easier to us as
English speakers because or speakers of
European languages because the word
order very often is more similar to what
we're used to and in many cases simpler
there's no there are no conjugations or
declensions to deal with it's I go today
I go tomorrow
very simple you go he go we go they go
it doesn't change but there are some
specific structures that are peculiar to
Chinese and you just have to get used to
and they seem strange at first
for example the we use the relative
pronoun which whereas in Chinese they
talk about the the you ate dinner the
dinner you ate is the you ate dinner so
there's some different orders there that
you have to get used to and they just it
just takes time so with enough reading
and listening it eventually starts to
feel natural there are more strange to
us structures in Japanese and you have
the problem of the different levels of
politeness which to some extent exists
in all languages but it's a much bigger
deal in Japanese and in Korean and for a
long time it just seems like you can't
get used to that but eventually you do
through enough exposure Korean right now
I'm experiencing a difficulty that the
way the future is constructed is I just
can't get my brain tied around it I've
seen the
explanations I've seen examples and when
I speak I have a lot of difficulty
coming up with those structures but I
know from previous experience that with
enough exposure enough listening and
reading eventually these structures will
become natural to me
so yeah Chinese easier than Japanese or
Korean insofar as the structure of the
language is concerned insofar as
pronunciation I think that Chinese is
the most difficult because of the tones
however the the actual sounds themselves
a lot of them are quite similar to
English there are some difficult sounds
but not so many and it's not surprising
that there are quite a few English
speakers who are absolutely fluent and
and flawless speakers of Chinese such as
the famous da Xiong who is Canadian who
is a personality on TV in China but I
think all three of them are fairly
straightforward when it comes to
pronunciation the tones are a problem in
Chinese and I think that's where you
didn't again you need to do a lot of
listening listening for the intonation
and as I've said many times I found it
very useful to listen to these young
strong comic dialogues because the
comedians exaggerate the intonation and
if you can get the intonation as part of
a series of phrases or even pick up on
the music of the language then the the
tones will slot into place not a hundred
percent but 60 70 80 percent of the time
as you get better at it as far as
understanding the language I think
Chinese probably represents the greatest
difficulty in terms of comprehension
because there are so many homonyms and
that is words that sound the same but
have different meaning and because
different parts of China have different
tones and pronounce these words
differently so that you know the true
sound is in some places the sure becomes
suit and so all of a sudden there's more
homonyms because they aren't
distinguishing between the juror and the
and the Hadza and
sure and the Sun so so Chinese from that
perspective is more difficult to
understand
I find Japanese quite easy to understand
and and Korean it's too early for me to
tell because I'm just I'm just getting
into it but I have the sense that there
again there are no tones to deal with in
Japanese or Korean so that makes it
easier to pronounce and easier to
understand when the language is spoken
one of the problems that I had with
Japanese but to some extent is true of
all languages is that I remember myself
being frustrated that so many of this
the words sounded the same kawari mas
Whakaari mas and it is a fact that
japanese has fewer sounds in it than
most languages I think it's of the
languages that I've learned it's the one
with the fewest different sounds so you
know this however many sounds khaki ku
ke ko times however many but so that
makes it more difficult at first because
the words have a tendency to sound the
same so difficulty I still say I mean I
find I found Russian difficult I find
trying to go from Russian into check
work it's similar but there are some
different structures it's always a
challenge and it's just a matter of
giving yourself enough time enough
exposure with the language not getting
frustrated when you go to speak and you
you can't quite get the hang of their
structure and you can't remember words
don't worry about it it with him if you
continue the intensive input eventually
these things will become more natural
the brain will pick it will get used to
it I don't care if you're an a westerner
learning an Asian language or an Asian
learning a Western language or you know
learning a language from the Amazon or
from I don't know and I'm a stray lien
Aboriginal language our brains will
eventually get used to the new patterns
and you just have to expose yourself
enough to it so to that extent
comparing the difficulty level of
Chinese Japanese I'm not sure that's
useful if you have Chinese and you go to
Japanese you're at a big advantage
because you already have the characters
hopefully if you're a Japanese person if
you're an Asian language speaker Nate
speaker otherwise learning another of
the East Asian languages you have of
course an advantage but I mean the
challenges of the language are there and
if you're motivated enough and you you
commit the time and if you're flexible
if you don't fight the new structures
and find them strange and resist them
and so forth
then you will learn them so yeah I don't
know if that answers the question
but talk for about almost 14 minutes on
the subject so I look forward to hearing
your comments thank you